this is a production of Cornell
University everybody today we're going
to talk about shortcake also going to
talk about a drum prediction woods up
here but maybe it's regain is something
about was business opportunity through
the ad that's chains and cars conception
and actually in Brazil in Brazil the top
producer followed by India and China and
part not being among the ten most
painted crop in the world in terms of
area and just are interesting for sure I
think a high qualified species so it's
actually the varieties the cones that we
see in the few today there are hybrids
from true qualified speeches in 2007 you
also are crossing and the clonally
propagated crop impacts on how we manage
the build environment and also train
your crops harvest happens every year
after a growing season ending
became think you got average of five
harvests from each problem so what do
genome selection sugarcane so you know
selection is being a tool that working
very well with quantitative traits and
those are the ones that are interesting
sugarcane so with being also shrinking
has really long cycles actually when
considered a cycle since this time
didn't we that we do across until the
time that we can do a cross again we've
real long and actually the traits that
are interesting are also quantitative
that's why we we went on to study how
can we or how good king genome selection
works for shirking review all my
presentation when we start having my
datasets both the molecular markers and
the field data and then for parents and
then another way of looking for to the
more for markers and shirking so I'm
gonna give an overview of the building
program working in broader so W program
is some selection states start with the
first age which is actually a family
stage where plant families are planted
together and evaluate it together for
traits like bricks and I think those
families that are selected the clones
that are the plans that are selected are
currently propagated plants are not only
propagated by doing with larger plots we
can have better phenotype of the plants
this happens normally around two years
one year to move from one stage you got
the third stage when having a bigger
plots
everything has measurements that we see
they're important for selection like
sucrose and weight
when we can see the performance of the
varieties a better resolution at the
same time here is two normally on a
single occasion and then on the
following stage then there's further
multiplication where things can be
evaluated in different locations and
actually through many more years so the
data that I'm using here comes from CTC
as Mark mentioned knowledge center in
Brazil here's translation here's the
overview of the headquarters and also
our breathing station that stays here
and enough for Brazil those are some
growing areas in Brazil the main growing
areas so let me go a little more in
details about my data's hands so I have
data from true breeding cycles I'm
calling cycle 5 in old seats they follow
the same scheme that I described in far
but on the third stage we had the actual
phenotyping that I'm gonna describe on
the first on the following chapter and
then use its own the third stage we got
data that were on all these traits
bricks all fiber and weight and also
sequencing data and from which we got is
new information so basically the Disney
the molecular marketing so much that we
have come from the third stage and we
have two cycles to to do our analysis so
just another statistics from these data
science here I'm showing the size of the
families in this third stage and we see
that okay we have some families that are
pretty large but most of them so that
there will be some imbalance in term
imbalance in terms of the the feminism
on the third stage
due to selection so let's take a look at
the molecular marker data so we did
sequencing for genotyping from about
2,000 samples we use the technology use
some probes to capture the locations in
the genome that we are actually getting
our sequencing from and then from that
we got a raw data set of more than 200
thousands niche that later was further
filtered out so we got to a final data
set with 55,000 markers in more than
1,700 clones
Marlin the molecular marking from ish so
here in my initial analysis I'm gonna
consider the is need information terms
of the presence of ABS or absence of the
alleles simulation when I use a simple
representation where I get a distinction
between the heterozygous state from the
homozygous a state only that we're going
to talk more about the the last section
of there with the market information
relationship we submitted a
relationships from the clones and I'm
going to show a broad view of the
relationship between the individuals
based on a piece for component analysis
here actually those three plots are the
same just the colors that are different
and what I'm showing here in the colors
are first here the cycles where the
clones came from so basically I'm
showing that there is no particular
difference between the clones of the
truth cycles in the other hand when I
start putting colors based on familiar
parents are made it won't come from we
start to see a relationship with others
and the dots so basically they structure
that we can see in the among those
clones modulated she did parents that
they came from
then from the cycle soon that kind of
makes sense when you see how the parents
were used in the different cycles you
have some overlap between parents and
also even when the parents don't don't
overlap they are related move on so we
also have pedigree information from
those clones that we use to estimate
relationships between the clones in here
do you have comparison between the
marker relationships and the pedigree
relationships that is an overall
correlation of 0.63 not that high
between those those estimates and you
are able to detect some outlier clones
that we decided to not use using the
following analysis basically they look
like replicated individuals maybe dip
there some is labeling and then these
comparison allowed us to do this
filtering yeah those are 17 cars okay so
I'm gonna show the first results that
are but genomic prediction for chrono
prediction so I'm just explaining what
we did so basically that analysis the
first step we got blues based on on the
rough phenotype records and then then
use those rules on a second step as our
optional type to do the predictions
together with the markers information
only data from here the linear model
that I use on the first step based on a
point out that we had a term for the
clones and also we controlled for
spatial relationships between the plants
on the field or on a second stage then
you have the linear model if two random
facts one that comes that's correlated
using the relationship derive is derive
some pedigrees and another from the
markers and I'm gonna do a comparison
later in which I use one term or the
other and here's how we're doing our
validation in of the predictors so
basically there are two they're going to
be true ways to compare one in which I'm
doing cross validation we've gone from
the cycle oops oh five which is a larger
data set and then
so basically splitting the data in tank
folds with six raptors and in another
approach we are going to use the whole
data set from cycle
oh five to predict the individual cycle
all six so here before showing the
results I'm gonna just presenting some
hurt ability broad sensor table
Testament here and I'm gonna also use
this to talk a little more about the
traits that I have so basically we have
the ones that I mentioned Greeks fiber
pole and weight but they were measured
in some combinations of conditions that
are different so we have a first harvest
and a second harvest for the stage three
data set and also have the this the
Asarco that I mentioned and we also have
two seasons so in both case half the
population will phenotype the beginning
of the season that's the early set and
then another half of the population in
the end of the season that's the delay
that's why we have so so many
combinations of the of the the traits
and then are basically considered a as
individual traits in these and Al's
so here is the first results from
cross-validation here then you have the
four traits Briggs fiber pole and weight
and harvest the first and the second
harvest and in these bars
have the both early and late trait and
you can see here that we have over our
prediction actresses ranging from a
little point one to close to point four
and there is actually not a clear trend
between harvest one and harvest true and
between oiling Li not say that that Kaos
always predict better for one or the
other and between the traits themselves
that in this particular case does
there's a little difference between them
but you can see that fiber is a bit
better then they wait these
cross-validation listen separating the
early in late SATs but another analysis
to put them together that I'm showing
here so basically by doing these
increase the training sets I have a
larger population to do my training and
then I can do prediction to both the the
same individual SATs early are late
ardent to predicting together in some
case that there was an increase of
prediction accuracy but it's not like
there's not a clear trend for all of
them actually these things and these
predictions I'm using both the molecular
marker ink the degree in the model so I
have that full model with those defects
and here I'm comparing what I get when
predicting only information so basically
the dots here are the same traits that I
was showing in the previous plot but now
the values are the accuracy things out
then you see that there is a train of
higher accuracy when using the markers
in comparison
and it's here and this one basically the
difference that include the previous
result here with markers in per degree
in compared with only the degree so they
look very similar which means that this
uh driving the increase in accuracy here
is the prediction for the markers so
let's move to their to the other skiing
of predict of validating the prediction
which I'm basically using the whole of
the whole cycle of five to predict the
whole cycle all six the same so here we
see a drop in prediction actresses for
for all of the Canes comparison to what
we had before and the same idea here
holds there's not a clear trend between
the harvests and the early the early
late season together for prediction in
this case we get some case actually here
in fiber are there is a bomb and the
prediction is a big drop
markers and degree now then is not super
clear distinction between there's not
not clear advantage for using the
markers in these final remarks that are
between these analysis so that there was
a first paper that reported general
prediction sugar cane was by a GUI arrow
in 2013 they actually had higher
accuracy for bricks and stock number we
charted two traits that we have in
common here actually I don't have stock
number but stock number is thought to be
as reported to be very correlated to
wait so maybe you can trace a comparison
in this case
they had similar hurt abilities but they
higher accuracy and there's one
important difference between the I study
and this one which is the population
composition so in their study they were
using varieties and clones derived from
bridging programs all over the world and
that I think that's the main difference
between the I study in this one here we
were doing a study based on clones
arrived at rebuilding program during the
selection and I think that can be
something to keep in mind when thinking
about implementing genome prediction in
a in a brilliant program forum self are
shrieking so some other comments on
regard to the prediction across cycles
actually we have we can see that there's
a lot of G by E so if it does not the
best way to compare there will be that's
expected to be a drop in the prediction
accuracy and the same way here was
interesting to do this comparison
because it kind of looks like what we
might observe when we first deploy
hurricane in a breeding program if we
also do the phenotyping of the the first
selection
I think if you had multiple year data
maybe could get some improvements in our
in our predictions and it got a better
clear view of the the trends with regard
to the g-body that's happened and then
we've got to whether to use markers of
the pretty degree for addiction observe
advantage when doing cross validation
and maybe this points to that we've used
these predictions families think we
would have a really clear advantage for
use in the markers in that case we can
connect up the prediction for using the
pretty good move on to another top which
is focus on predicting parental
breathing values so basically I'm using
the same data set as before but instead
of predicting the clonk performance as I
did I'll look to the parents from that
derived those clones in the building
program and our estimate bringing values
for them and also all the records and
I'm gonna put together data from stage 1
and stage 3 in that case we're gonna
have a kind of very unbalanced data set
we have parents that have from two to
more than 200 records available in this
case so the Britney valves values are
gonna be derived from a bar Aladdin's
little sense and also because I don't
have markers on the parents for this
data set I'm gonna use the approach by
llegará 2009 which called the H matrix
which is a combination between the
pedigree relationship matrix and the
marker relationship matrix basically it
came
expand some of the marker information to
the whole matrix using this approach and
just as a comparison here when I
correlated the pedigree matrix to the H
matrix only on on the set of cones that
don't have marker information be having
relation of point seven three if you
remember before we had in a correlation
of point six point six three so they are
still not super highly correlated so
there is this kind of shows how one
information push the other so here's my
linear mixed model there's a bunch of
letters here but what I want to focus is
on on determine G which is the random
effect for the genotype and then these
random fact will use this H matrix that
I'm talking about actually sometimes I'm
gonna use the H matrix sometimes we're
going to use the pedigree matrix so I'm
gonna do prediction using the range
compared to the pretty gray to the
pretty value derived from the image in
this case I'm gonna do prediction across
psychosis again using all records from
2005 to form that the training set and I
use the parents that are only in 2006 as
my validation data sets so here's the
results so basically we have predictions
in which I'm using the pedigree in our
College the pedigree with relationships
the H matrix and also an HDI blue matrix
that I'm calling here in each I form the
subset of the data for which I have both
marker and pedigree information with
both matrices
and then in this case that there was a
higher prediction accuracy for for
weight but in general there was very
little increase for using the marker
information and even decrease when using
weight another comparison that I did
here was to include in the observed data
the decide the previous cycle which is
kind of and kind of reusing the same
data that I'm using as training but
that's what brings the best best
estimates for the brainy values and then
there is a real big increase in
prediction accuracy here I would say
that actually the act the real
prediction accuracy that we might expect
is not beside it should be something
here later lower but I'd like to show
these results so to have another
information mind another comparison that
we did was to loop to the parents and
and see if we there are some full sibs
there so basically had a couple of
families in the parent days and with an
average of a bit more than five clones
per family and we did the same estimates
of correlation that we did before but
now only looking to those full sibs
handles and in this case we can still do
a good prediction for what wait but
there is a sharp decrease for our greens
I tested actually the significance of
this as my imagine there might be a lot
of variation for this small number of
and actually the standard deviations you
are pretty high so if I do a t-test it's
going to be it's not going to be a
significance
so it'll be interesting to do this
analysis again with a larger number of
families our larger families some
remarks here so in this case when
interesting thing was to use the progeny
data to do our predictions and compares
what we did before which was the data
derived from the clones themselves and
so I think that we're able to combine
data from many states and for years and
after the the mixed models allowed to
spite of that tool to analyze this very
imbalance and then a comparison between
markers and pedigree prediction you can
see that actually again we have probably
a better use of the market information
when you look to prediction we think
families and also in this and as we
could use this H matrix which kind of
make it easier to use Drax's information
that we might read having the brilliant
program but for which we don't have a
marker information yet
okay so so in this last section I'm
gonna talk about something a little
different so I said in the beginning
that sure canes a polyploid species and
I was only looking to they're markers in
a very simple way only looking to the
presence or absence of the marker of
daily use there so actually we know that
we might have more information there
right because it's a polyploid so in
this section I'd like to explore a bit
more on the markers this is a diagram
that's pretty common to seeing shuriken
presentations that kind of shows how the
chromosomes which sure can look like and
so here they're putting the colors to
each of the species that form the
hybrids and then the main thing that I
like to point here is that yeah we have
many copies from each of the chromosomes
so that's why it's polyploid and also we
have like aneuploidy so we have
different numbers of of flight levels
for each chromosome and actually this
might happen even between clones so if I
go to another cone I do not that these
numbers for the same chromosome should
be the same kind of make things a bit
complicated here so here I'm gonna I'm
showing a bit more on detail on what I
mean by this
but what's happening to the marker so it
might be might happen again not on the
polypoid button outer pool boy that we
can observe markers in high higher
dosage so you might have things that we
observe deploy like a single copy or
absence but also higher dosage of the
alleles and basically that's the kind of
difference that i'm missing in my
previous analysis
so that's one question that you might
have is okay does it matter does it
matter the dosage my happy that like
after a dosage of zero like when I
compared to my traits of each increase
the presence of the Leo amor office
doesn't matter anymore it might happen
that it really matters that as I get
more higher dosage I have a higher
impact on my trade or something crazy to
the dosage or not we do eat you're not
having the chance to look to this okay
so is it easy to to look to that and
there are reports in the literature that
explored this idea of looking to the
marker information that you get from a
population and try to identify infer
Kane what's the dosage even in the case
of values that appear in higher dosage
it turns out that it's kind of hard
there are a lot of changes that we we
kind of don't see a clear result and
then here I'm kind of summarizing what I
think are the problems in in looking to
the higher dosage restriction so if
you're doing an analysis of markers for
those Egyptian first of all we need to
know what's the dosage that we we have
on a given locus I mean the maximum
dosage are the quite level but we don't
know this information yes
maybe you should couldn't have an
approach that through the analysis gives
this flight level that's another
possibility but it's hard to do another
things that sure Kings highly
heterozygote species and as other plants
we might observe a lot of duplications
of genes and and so on so it might
happen that big the signal that we are
observing here and you can see new to me
the Millat remark information that it
gets be it for instance in our case the
sequencing information from looks we you
want that signal to be really derived
from every single allele that observed
on the locus but due to hetero zygosity
we might not do or actually might get
signal from more than the moon was high
together when we were clustering the
sequence information so there are some
difficulties here and another is
actually that we want the signal
information the the reads that you get
from sequencing in our case to the
number of ways to be a function of the
dosage and for instance if you have a
narrow read sequencing we that might be
a problem we do to sampling errors we
might get a different number of reads
than what we would expect from the
dosage so what I'm gonna do here is to
try to avoid some of these questions so
I'm gonna do an analysis that simplifies
how we look to the marker data which is
use signal directly without doing any of
those fancy statistics and Allison
democra data in which we find the dosage
itself so examples of these later but
I'm gonna use that so we can't test this
question that I made a few minutes ago
is it worth it to use the dosage
information when doing
instead of analysis in sugarcane maybe
it's not worth it so maybe a simpler
analysis in which we just look to the
presence and absence of values that's
enough and that you can't do better than
that so I'd like to and another thing is
okay we do all these analysis trying to
find the dosage of like as I shown in
the literature I'll find it the dosage
information from the markers and maybe
if you if you can test that this the use
of this information is valuable then you
don't give more incentives to follow on
that and we are going to do this through
both 2oz engineering prediction so a
building on the previous results we're
going to do a an analysis in which I
have their markers on a simpler
representation and order in which that
doesn't take into account the those at
your formation and other that does and
compare the results
oops so basically I'm going to reuse the
information that I got before that we
had before and here I'm going to explain
what I mean by another representation of
their markers so I'm showing in this
table or data points for snips and here
I have weed counts from both of those
I'll use from these names so in one case
for instance I've read counts from my
whip reference to you but not for my
alternative value in my what a called
discrete genotype or discrete coding of
the marker information our sign a value
let's say zero to this case I mean I
have both alleles I'm gonna say it's a 1
and when I don't have one of the other
Olivos it's true that's basically what I
did before
but induce new approach but I call a
continuous coding of the genotype I
basically get the ratio between the the
read counts from the reference value to
the total number of reads that I have so
I will have something that's continuous
so that goes from zero to one and that
allows me to distinguish distinguish
cases like this that might have and the
assumption is that if I have a higher
dosage
I'll have higher read counts for that
illegal
so using this discontinuous genotype for
four so here's an example of how that
works in the actual data that we have so
I'm showing here one is neap and another
is need this is me on top you have the
continuous coding and on bottom the
discrete coding and those are the like
histograms from my values 1 & 2 but in
the continuous causing this value that's
the heterocycles range of values that go
from this kind of flipped so these guys
here appear okay and this might be
interesting because then you get a
higher resolution for these it also only
had one so if you're working with a deep
these to happen only have heterozygous
individuals in our approach but ensuring
that happen at least it happens in my
dataset
basically I throw out markers like this
in a discrete analysis is that between
one and another and so what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna do - I have two matrices one
calling D from disparate and see some
continues it markers in both
representations and from the markers
under that are like this so with extra
markers that I didn't have access to
before so I had some samples that her
work or replicated so I did an analysis
taking four counts this the Obsidian our
servers are replicated in gnome
replicated and compared those two
distances to find an optimal read death
for futuring these snips
so the optimal one is actually 80 I used
some 50 just to not lose that many snips
but no significant difference here so
using it is the DC and c2 the same train
here the same stage three homes that I
use we see that using discrete coding
and same markers I got the first very
similar actually we have point nine to
this diagonal elements
[Music]
okay I might have and I do my heart
apart becomes very messy difficult to
see a clear trend so actually continuous
and speed coding in a manner which is
going over a range of thresholds that of
just using for a range of threshold I
count the number of significant hits
that I have four for that here in this
plot I'm showing the number of hits that
with that and on rad been using this
discrete coding so higher number of hits
and well actually if you do this analogy
here
holding have more markers but forth in
this case I just compared the C and the
B movies and you see we have a higher
number of hits that case talking getting
more markers due to the use of the CR I
also but they are just check it for
markers that are not significant how
many of them are significant for the
game modeling based because of the
likelihood is not directly comparable
between both so we see here increase in
the number of weeks and 15% more
compared to the number of markers that
we get from only using linear model so I
used develop modeling but also some
artists modern ways of modeling the data
are ths support vector machines and rain
forests so those are the results or
genomic blob in the four traits and the
different matrices so let's focus on
this one most of the case there are a
slight improvement in using this
continuous coding and even when I use
the cecum it has I didn't show the
numbers here but my situated has only so
here we're talking about 50,000 markers
the C 2 matrix has 5000 markers if you
have a high and well not not always but
in general there there's a little
increase in predict trends include the
other models for John prediction I don't
see I don't observe a real improvement
between the different models and
sometimes it gets really works so I'm
gonna stick with two random effects and
that didn't I'm not going to show here
but it didn't improve much of this
continuous coding actually provided some
gain in information so I have some have
more markers that were not polymorphic
before because of the relationships were
a little different it looks like we're
getting access to new information that
we didn't have before the actual pass
and you also had more hits
so non prediction it was about the same
so it's not clear whether it was a real
improvement in accuracy there but I
think we can say that to use some forms
of dosage encoding in studies for sure
can might be beneficial so that's what
we are actually investigating
in shops like you I think some people so
especially so all these I study was my
PhD the whole program the data
everything comes from from CDC and
actually a lot of people there that
contributed to get the data
imagine the the feud records everything
consistent childhood they were directly
involved in establish the framework for
this project and also Michael
Butterfield and William Burton they were
responsible for actually sponsoring
everything yeah I also like to thank a
lot my speciality mark John Lou Jim
booth especially mark for accepting
accepting me here and guiding through
all those years and supporting every
staff and also I'd like to think about
all the sorrows and teen we interacted a
lot through those years I learned a lot
through that here and bring in this odd
picture because I think has some folks
that I'm not here anymore
I'd like to especially mention then in
September make San Antonio and Gucci
it's not here that we gave a lot of
include to my analysis so that's it for
today
I have a question about your prediction
between cycles you talked about the
common parents they were subsets that
were used in both cycles I'm wondering
if just from those original predictions
you did if you ever look at the accuracy
on the cycle you were predicting just
for the common parents because you
should be able to predict within family
better than just across so you're
suggesting to use the premise that I had
in common look at the accuracy what I
was thinking you use the whole training
population into the prediction but then
you know maybe you're predicting so that
when you are late with the whole group
eat that's what showed but just look in
those common I actually I actually did
that just not showing I that there is a
higher accuracy super high but yeah it's
higher than that significantly higher I
should have included your concern
between when you look at your dosage of
an allele there you if there's a you
know are you looking at a difference in
whether or not you haven't read depth or
whether or not so ideally we would be
looking to the dosage that's the what we
actually have in the plans is the dosage
not worth the read counts so the thing
is we don't have access to that
information
yes I'm not sure if you're gonna get a
day half finish working so I'm trying to
to here actually not propose that we
should use the read that and I think we
still need to find a way to get the
actual dosage but what I try to do was
through
try to ask a question okay is it worth
it to look should we do that because
actually I had this this question when
it when I got here and that's why my oh
my mission Alice's her based only on the
presence or absence of markers and if I
went to do an a dosage actual dosage and
else probably I would be working with
way fewer markers than I have now
and actually it's pretty complicated to
do that so so so actually not proposing
to you but can we use to answer some by
using another way - this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at Cornell edu